Christian Noël assiste au
sommet.
(violons)
Des musiciens qui onssssssé
par toute la gamme des émotions.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'orchestre symphonique de Kiev,
bouleversée par la guerre, est
venu faire vibleleles dirigeants
des pays membres de l'OTAN.
Une mélodie pour toucher
les coeurs.
Une ouverture sur la culture
qu'ils tentent de protéger.
plus tôt dans la journée, le
Canada et alalalliés ont promis
de soutenir davantage l'Ukraine.
"En modernisant uiuiuipement
ukrainien, dit-il,
et en augmentant la force
de dissuasion de l'OTAN."
Les États-Unis annoncent donc
une augmentation significative
de leur présence en Europe.
Un quartier général permanent de
l'armée américaine en Pologne,
des avions de chasse stationnés
en Grande-Bretagne, des systèmes
aéaéaériens en Allemagne
et en Italie.
Le Canada, quant à lui, apporte
une contribution pmomomodeste.
D'abord sur le plan
diplomatique...
- Nous allons ouvrir quatre
nouvelles ambassades.
- Puis sur le plan militaire.
- Aujourd'hui, nous signons un
partenariat avec le gouvernement
de la Lettonie.
- Le nombre de soldats de l'OTAN
en Lettonie va augmenter,
et c'est l'armée canadienne qui
sera responsable de commander
cette nouvelle brigade.
- Et nous augmentons
considérablement
nos contributions de l'OTAN
en Letnininie.
- "Si l'Ukraine s'effondre,
dit-il, la prochaine guerre
sera chez nous."
Toutefois, la ministre Anand est
incapable de précicococombien
de soldats supplémentaires
seront déployés en Lettonie.
STÉFANIE VON HLATKY, professeure
études politiques, Univ. Queen's
- Si le Canada ne réussit pas
à répondre à toutes les demandes
et exigences de l'OTAN, ce que
les Forces armées canadiennes
peuvent offrir aussi, c'est
un rôle de leadership.
- Les attentes envers le Canada
sont grandes. L'OTAN fait
à nouveau pression pour une
augmentation des dépenses
militaires, mais le niveau
de 2 % du PIe e e le Canada n'a
jamais atteint, est maintenant
considéré comme le strict
minimum. Les engagementsd'd'd'an
d'atteindre la cible